one conspiracy theory that i subscribe
to is that corporate media headlines are
created by the use of some sort of
random
current event buzzword generator and i'm
beginning to think that journalists and
news anchors themselves personally are
created in a laboratory through a
similar process and this theory was
further legitimized over the weekend
when cnn published an article with the
following headline
joe rogan's use of the n-word is another
january 6th moment
now this would have been the perfect
headline if only they'd found a way to
jam a climate change reference in there
as well as it stands i have to grade it
in eight out of ten pretty solid work
though cnn was embarrassed by the
mockery that followed and they soon
changed the headline to
why shrugging off joe rogan's use of the
n-word is so dangerous
yes it is quite dangerous to shrug at a
word the most dangerous kind of shrug of
all in fact
but this headline is still very stupid
sadly it lacks the comedic punch of the
first headline sequels rarely live up to
the originals especially in the comedy
genre but the article itself remained
unchanged and it's worth reading some of
this
here's what it says the podcaster joe
rogan did not join a mob that forced
lawmakers to flee for their lives he
never carried a confederate flag out
inside the u.s capitol rotunda no one
died trying to stop him from using the
n-word but what joe rogan and those that
defend him have done since videos clips
of him uh using the n-word surfaced on
social media is arguably just as
dangerous as what a mob did when they
stormed the u.s capitol on january 6
last year
of course by the way nobody died trying
to stop the capital rioters either but
who has time for such minor details
things like the truth who has time for
that nobody does it continues
rogan breached a civic norm that has
held together since world war ii it's an
unspoken agreement that we would never
return to the kind of country we used to
be
that agreement revolved around this
simple rule a white person would never
be able to publicly use the n-word again
and not pay a price
rogan has so far paid no steep
professional price for using a racial
slur that's been called the nuclear bomb
of racial slurs it may even boost his
career that's why some that's what some
say happened to another white
entertainer who was recently caught
using the word it's a sign of how
desensitized we've become to the rising
levels of violence rhetorical and
physical in our country that rogan's
slur was treated as the latest racial
outrage of the week but once we allow a
white public figure to repeatedly use
the phallus racial epithet in the
english language without experiencing
any form of punishment we become a
different crunch country we accept the
mainstreaming of a form of political
violence
that's as dangerous as a january 6th
attack
now it's hard to know where to begin
first we have the casual way that words
and physical violence are equated
rhetorical violence as the author puts
it uh it may be hard for those of us
raised on these sticks and stones may
break my bones philosophy to understand
how any adult person especially a man
and i think this article was written by
an alleged man could actually claim with
any kind of straight face that a word
has done violence to him
but what you have to understand is that
we live in the age of psychological man
or a person's emotional and
psychological comfort is considered to
be the number one priority
emotional
is emotions is they're not just on par
with physical well-being but actually
they're prioritized over it this is why
for example a person who feels
distraught over their body their
biological identity is encouraged to
mutilate their body for the sake of
their psychological self-identity rather
than working to change their
psychological self-identity to better
comport with their bodies your your
psychological self-identity your
emotional well-being that is the number
one most important thing
in this context you see how a word or
idea or opinion or joke which causes
emotional discomfort becomes an even
worse form of violence
than a bullet to your head
or a blade to your stomach
but there's something else going on here
too
he says that there's a social contract a
social norm
that we've all agreed to which declares
that a white person can never say
this certain word in any context
last night's singer india arie was on
the daily show
continuing her campaign against joe
rogan and she made a similar point
listen
when you know you're doing it
and like you said in your monologue if a
person keeps doing it is that what we
call them a-races so if you know you're
doing it and you keep doing it i would
say that is a racist
and so for me when i think about
i want to be nice i was going to say
this name that i'm tired of saying but
for me when i think about joe rogan
i think
i think that he is being consciously
racist
i mean since the early 1900s we've had
an agreement in our society that we
don't say the word or people or you have
to suffer the consequences right and so
saying it and then being like what are
you gonna do oh sorry i didn't mean that
or i i didn't understand there was no
context under which i should say it
i don't believe that i think he knew
there was no context i think that's why
he was saying it because he got a rise
out of people that's why he would say it
he knew that it was inappropriate and i
think the fact that the fact that he did
it repeatedly and was conscious and new
i think that is
being
racist
i like how she pretends she didn't want
to say joe rogan's name i don't know i i
told myself i wasn't going to say his
name that's the only reason you're being
interviewed the whole reason you're on
the daily show to talk about joe rogan
like no one else no one wants to talk to
india re for any other reason okay
uh that's the whole reason you're there
is to talk about joe rogan and by the
way uh we should also mention with with
uh trevor noah that he you know he's
he's very much been part of this effort
to cancel joe rogan and uh
uh but
you may have seen some of the
screenshots
circulating on twitter's from several
years ago
when uh trevor noah was first announced
as the replacement for um
for
uh
for the daily show for jon stewart
all of these jokes that he had made in
his past came to the surface and there
was this cancel campaign against trevor
noah and guess who came to his defense
none other than joe rogue joe rogan came
out said he was just a joke everyone
back off
and to repay that trevor noah flips it
around and uh joins the mob against him
because that's what these people are are
made of on the left
now
we're told that there's this rule that
we all agreed to
the problem is that we did not all agree
to this rule i i didn't agree to it i
don't agree to it
i'm a part of society also and i haven't
signed any social contract which
declares that the right to use a word
any word depends on your skin pigment or
your country of origin
i don't agree to any rule which allows a
member of one racial group to say a word
six thousand times a day if they want
while a member of another
group cannot utter it in any context at
all no matter what
i don't agree to any rule which says
that context doesn't matter when it
comes to language context always matters
you cannot know what anyone is saying or
understand anyone's meaning if you
ignore context
context is always important
in fact she
she
uh contradicts herself in what she's
saying right there because she says oh i
he he used the word that he knew was
offensive and he said it because he was
trying to get a rise out of people
okay well if you think that was the
context that he was trying to get a rise
out of people and he was just saying it
because it's offensive and he's trying
to get attention
i don't know if that's true or not but
if that's true that means it's not
racist
that means his intention was not to be
racist it was just to get attention or
to be offensive for the sake of being
offensive
that you could say what you want about
someone doing that but it's not racist
it's just it's that's the motivation
according to you
well the context doesn't matter
i also have not consented to whatever
consequences cnn or india re or trevor
noah you know think ought to be doled
out to the violators of this agreement
that i never signed
i don't agree to any of it
most everyone in the country has not
agreed to any of this
and that's because it's not our rule
it's not society's rule
it's their rule
the leftist elite have come up with
these social directives these kind of
cultural regulations
and they demand adherence
and will attempt to punish anyone who
does not adhere
what we have to understand is that to
the leftist elite
their social edicts and ordinances are
the most important rules the most sacred
law the only law really this is part of
the reason why they've given up on
enforcing the actual written law
the law that says you can't do stuff
like you know rob and kill people
partly they've abandoned that kind of
law and order because they want to
destabilize civilization but also
their heart isn't in it
all that matters to them is that you
follow their rules
rules against hurting and killing people
i mean physically hurting and killing
people not emotionally hurting and
killing them
they've been in place in every
civilization in one form or another
since the dawn of time
the left cannot claim credit for those
rules didn't invent them
and thus doesn't care about them
so they're not emphasized
and sometimes are directly and
purposefully de-emphasized
for example a woman in new york uh named
christina yuna lee was murdered inside
her apartment by a homeless drifter just
last week the daily mail has some of the
details it says a homeless serial
criminal accused of murdering an ad
creative after following her into her
apartment um knifed the woman 40 times
with one of her own knives and had a
sexual motive for doing so accord heard
asamod nash was charged with sexually
motivated burglary by prosecutors on
monday as was revealed his victim
christina yuna lee was found topless in
the bathtub of her chinatown apartment
on sunday
the charge suggests a possible motive
for the brutal murder which shocked nyc
and raised fresh questions about new
york state's bail reforms after it was
revealed that nash was a serial criminal
on bail for robbery when he allegedly uh
did the killing well of course he was on
bail that's the detail you can always
count on finding in any of these stories
about violent scumbags randomly
assaulting or killing innocent people
they're always on bail
now it turns out that nash had a lengthy
rap sheet stretching back years he's
been a violent worthless societal leech
for a long time but here are the
highlights from just the past year
so according to court records access by
dailymail.com nash has been arrested
four times in the last year alone his
rap sheet included misdemeanor charges
of assault intentional damage to
property harassment resisting arrest
both attempted and successful escape
from police officers and selling a fare
card three of these cases remain open
and he has appeared in court on numerous
occasions he was set to appear again
before a judge on march 9 on the assault
harassment and intentional damage to
property charges
now it doesn't matter how often this
sort of thing happens
the left will keep pushing for things
like bail reform
ensuring that more and more violent
criminals are put back on the street
even after they've been arrested because
these rules are not their rules
they quite sincerely feel more outrage
about joe rogan saying a naughty word
than they do about a woman getting
stabbed to death in her apartment by a
drug-addled vagrant not only because the
vagrant's race makes him still a victim
according to their narrative but also
because the vagrant didn't break any
rule that they invented
he violated a different code the legal
code
for one
but also the moral code written in our
hearts by natural law and codified by
every human civilization since time and
memorial
they don't care about that
what matters most is their rule book
which they came up with
and which they add to every day
and whose violators they believe
should pay the harshest penalty of all
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated